it's worse than you all realize
it's not just about police who stood
back and did nothing from timcast.com
border patrol team who ultimately killed
the shooter were blocked from entering
the school by uvaldi police for nearly
an hour why doesn't make any sense
these people were
not only were they cowards but they were
obstructing the parents and the border
patrol
this is something something is wrong
here something's really scary something
is seriously wrong here
now they're saying they they thought the
children were at risk and so they didn't
want to risk it by storming in or
something like that
and now they're saying it was a big
mistake
i don't buy it uh you for you to stand
outside that room hearing gunshots
knowing there are children inside even
if you don't hear gunshots if you know
children had been shot an hour ago right
you still can't go in
there are kids who are shot inside can't
go in what do they think was gonna
happen like he after he killed all the
kids he wasn't a threat anymore he's
still got a gun look let them run out of
bullets first
that's crazy apparently had like what
like 1 600 rounds
we need right now for our future
generations
heroes to look up to
you know we need we need a story
about
one of these cops what should have
happened
storming in kicking the door in pulling
out their service weapon and
ending this this this
psychopath
and then telling people about how he
risked everything to save these kids and
that's what you want to be when you grow
up yeah well the border patrol agent who
actually did eventually kill him right
was getting his haircut
his wife his wife texted him and said
there's an active shooter in the school
help and i'm sure you can find that
article and he was in the barber shop he
didn't have his uh weapon on him but his
barber had a shotgun holy cow the
barber's shotgun and drove to the school
that's amazing he is the one that's the
story you can find the story yeah that
dude needs a move that dude and he's the
one who who eventually killed the
shooter but i'm sure you can find the
article let me pull that up that is the
culture that's been in this world for a
while that is absolutely in the dna of
every cop and every military official
and every cia officer that i've worked
with i i would say in the vast majority
of cases that's what drives people to
show up is doing exactly what he did off
duty wasn't his responsibility doesn't
matter it was still his mission because
it was his community it was his country
that's what people dream of when they
join the forces good people dream of
having that moment when they can jump up
grab the nearest available weapon and
make it happen well i wanted to say
before we move to this really
interesting sounding story i think that
this might be the result of what
happened during the pandemic when they
were locking down they were enforcing
all these unconstitutional rules and the
good cops were like i'm out bye so we're
left with cowardly cops who watched what
happened during the blinds i don't know
if he was the guy who actually killed
the shooter they say it was uh a cbp uh
boar tech is that vortech border
tactical yeah that confronted him but
this he this guy did run in with his
barber's shotgun oh he saved his wife
and daughter okay yeah yeah that's
amazing
an amazing story and these are the guys
those are the ones we need to make hero
movies yes yep
i mean
how would you do it it would be short
sure it's like it's just a a dad who
said i've gotta i've gotta save my
family you know
you know again i what i would love to
know is about this man's life
what
drove him in his life to become who he
became what in his childhood in his
young adulthood what made him decide
that in that moment sit in that barber
chair
that he has this beautiful family that
he was going to either try to save them
or he would know that as he was trying
to save his family he could be shot and
killed and he would be gone and his
family would have to survive without him
but he still got himself out of that
chair grabbed that shotgun and ran
there's something interesting and
beautiful about his soul that i would
love to understand because that's
exactly what we need to uplift and
celebrate yeah it's actually a good
origin story for his kid to be like if
you were doing a movie about it about
someone here or like like a marine or a
law enforcement guy did something great
and it's like his origin was that his
dad risked his life and that was the
message he got and that's why he went on
to become a hero i'm gonna tell you what
what this guy is he is a normal man who
did something extraordinary
because that's what in in history of
this country it's not somebody who was
born in some fancy family right it was a
normal person who was put in an
extraordinary situation and did
something extraordinary with the power
of that moment i don't know when i think
of the carries and the bushes and some
of the prestigious families of the
country they've done amazing things
just absolutely it's amazing indeed
i'm definitely amazed when i think about
this yeah he took his barbarous shotgun
he actually helped evacuate people out
of the building well we do we have medal
of honor for uh police local state
police things like that i don't know
maybe we should but i wanted to add
before we move on because our chat's
full of people screaming fed is that
this guy worked for the federal
government he worked for the border
patrol he wasn't a local cop the local
cops didn't do jack deep state
that's it
was here to help us you raised a great
question though the is there a medal of
honor an award will this guy be
recognized it will be curious the next
state of the union is in uh uh seven
months
whoever order patrol whoever the
president invites to his balcony is
always a very important very symbolic i
will bet right now that biden will take
someone from buffalo to highlight the
racism angle because that is what we do
in our politics he will not take a hero
and say this is a guy who risked
everything he will take a victim and say
and it's because of this country that
victimhood like this exists because
you're all bad vote for me again so
that's what i think is going to happen
it's a little speculative of me but uh
i don't think they'll build a statue for
this guy no no but they built a statue
for george floyd yes saint pray for us
saint george who was on fentanyl at the
time of death oh more than that yeah
five no he should not have died i mean
i'm not trying to say that in any way
but we don't want to make those guys
heroes no george floyd died and it's
tragic and uh in in many ways you know i
also think that he was a flawed human
being
we don't want people just to die but we
don't tell our children to look up to
the people who are who are who are dying
in these tragic things and who have
lived pretty bad lives
we want kids to look up to this guy
jacob
uh albarado i don't know his name who
was getting a haircut yeah and then
decides he gets a text from his wife
that's the story and then says you know
she says i love you and he rushes in to
help save i mean you want to save his
family but he helps evacuating a bunch
of other people too get jacob alvarado
on the show that is a great idea might
have to try that yeah i think you know
just wait and you asking the question
where did you come from well he's also
known he's also cbp so i'd love to talk
to him oh for sure yeah i'll get a lot
of questions yeah yeah he'll be great
guys ask him if they really whip people
oh yeah
austin
and i was thinking at hotel and flipping
through the channels i can't remember
which news station turned on
automatically and it was this
documentary
and it was just the weirdest
jesse smollette level hoax bs leftist
propaganda
and it was playing this dark music and
showing all these awful photos of like
trump supporters and trump looking angry
and then it showed the border patrol guy
with the the reign yeah please or they
tried to convince people he was whipping
them it's just not real no these people
believe jesse smollette hoaxes every
single day jesse's is free again right
like is that that's what i heard last
night he hasn't been put back in jail
well that's right
he's still yeah but you know what's next
they're not real yeah for sure
so am i going to be run out of this
place
no absolutely not i prefer the term
administrative state there you go yes
speaking of you were part of the
administrative state i was that's true
why did you leave
uh two reasons the first was uh my
brother was uh
still as an alcoholic but needed to be
in rehab so i left to go make a bunch of
money to get him into rehab so thank god
he's sober and doing better now
uh the other uh was i saw a lot of
people
who no longer were there for the right
reasons
um i can't talk a lot about the programs
that i was involved in but the upshot is
that they were lying to the white house
and the nsc and the oversight committees
about how successful we were being at
certain things
and i was like you guys are that this is
incorrect
and
they basically just told me to go f
myself right so after a while you know
you were baptized as i was you know born
and raised in rural america my family
loved the country and you know cousins
who joined them you know military and
all that
so joining the cia was an extension of
that so you would have thought as i i
did for many years that everybody would
want to to remain committed to the
mission to the country
but then i got to this level where i'm
involved in various programs and i'm
watching them lie
to our elected leaders which i don't
know in hindsight like how naive of me
not to think that some of my colleagues
would lie to protect themselves so they
could get promoted right but it was so
just disheartening that i was like i'm
not going to spend another 20 years of
my life
to around these people who aren't here
for the right reason i i got it i'm out
i'm done so do you think does the cia
have a little bit of an enron problem
where the the numbers are inflated but
everyone likes the cons of the result
and so they're like yeah this is great
great
in insider knowledge here every two
years or so people rotate out of
positions
so you want to be able in your
evaluation you want people to say oh
things were better than when you got
here
nobody wants to say hey when i got into
this position actually did a little bit
of scrubbing and this is a bunch of
[ __ ]
the programs that we're telling the
downtown that is say the white house and
congress that are all great actually
they're garbage nobody wants to be that
guy so everybody waits two years and
then leaves so everybody kicks this this
corrupt can down the road and so that's
what's happening inside the agency to
this day so term limits for
administrative state this has been
brought up to me multiple times and i'm
i'm a fan what you're saying is
absolutely solidifies my belief in that
if they're waiting two years to get in a
promotion or to get and they'll just say
whatever they need to say i mean that's
that's the deepest darkest crap
so whether it's i don't know what the
solution is other than uh
you've got to have more sunshine into
those kinds of systems and you have to
have
people you know raise their hand to the
inspector general etc to say hey there's
an issue but ultimately this is about
the the house and the senate the
oversight committees and their staffs
knowing what questions to ask and
holding the people and power to account
and that's true the fbi too that's what
has failed over these past number of
years with all these fbi agents who did
this ridiculous crap in michigan you
know setting those those those guys up
uh we saw it with guys like uh john
brennan who knew damn well that there
was no trump russia collusion but he
left the agency and he went around the
country for two years saying it was all
but true if not absolutely true and he
knew it wasn't i knew oh james clapper
as well sorry
he had another one clapper with when
they're talking about the prism spying
network that they had uncovered and
asked if they'd been spying on american
people his response was not wittingly
knowing full well yes you have been
spying on the americans built a big
station like a big building in the
middle of nowhere to do it under oath he
perjured himself congress did nothing so
here's here's what the deep state is i'm
going to give you an example a guy named
aldridge ames he was a cia officer back
in the 1990s and he decided he was going
to spy for the soviet union
and so he did and he was caught by the
fbi and they asked him aldrich why'd you
do it
and he said because i know
what's best for this country and its
national security and i'm going to act
on it
so the deep state are these people have
profound powers
who decide that based on their own
politics their own beliefs they're going
to do whatever the hell they want to do
irrespective of the law and then they
get away with it so was it like a
corporate governance basically that got
built in 1946 is that right after world
war ii eisenhower basically put this
thing together that's the up the upshot
yeah through the second world war there
was something called the oss that was
kind of the external intelligence
service and then obviously the fbi
proceeded that but um yeah it was this
uh
there was a need
for foreign intelligence to understand
what our adversaries are doing and to
get ahead of that right so i get the
need and that remains but the problem is
when you give people and any human power
some percentage of them are going to
abuse it and the more power that you
give them
at some level you're gonna have more and
more people who abuse it it's just the
nature of humanity so how do you how do
you bridle that how do you manage it and
there are different people who answer
that in different ways maybe you don't
do it at all because it's just too risky
so you get rid of the cia altogether or
yeah you manage it better i always
wonder if the deep state is the
and correct me the organization itself
is so big and so well entrenched that by
the time there's a new president and
they switch out john podesta for who's
the guy now bill barber bill burr is the
comedian yeah hopefully it'll be bill
burceau
by the time you swap these people out it
doesn't matter who's at the top like i'm
doing my thing and you know he doesn't
know i exist i know who he is just to
stay out of his hair is there some truth
to the fact that the apparatus is so big
that the people at the top they rotate
no one cares that's absolutely true and
this gets back to the point that was
made about the the whether it be term
limits uh even in your your bureaucracy
or mid-level guys or or it's just a size
issue you you just expanded the state in
the past 20 30 years to such an extent
that that there are so many people who
have so many entrenched interests that a
it slows down your mission but then b
you get more and more people who can do
more and more damage to your country
because you give them such expansive
powers so i'm a big fan of actually
reducing not just the size of government
generally speaking which it's true but
specifically the the deep state as it
were the agency the fbi i certainly
think the administrative state the deep
state whatever you call it is a serious
problem
but uh
what about the argument and i'm not
saying it's a good argument i'm just
saying this is the argument made that if
we curtail our powers internationally
and domestically china will take over
and then we'll be living in a unipolar
chinese superpower you know planet so
here's the deal cia ain't gonna stop
this yeah uh china
the cia and the fbi are not gonna stop
china
the fbi starts at least 10 cases every
day against china right now we have over
a hundred thousand chinese nationals who
come into this country every year so the
issue isn't
it is like a damn
that's bursting we're trying to put our
finger in it to stop it
you have good leadership within the
white house and the house and the senate
that that understands that china is a
threat and starts treating them as such
the spies ain't gonna fix this one the
fbi ain't gonna fix this they just won't
so we don't need to expand the
administrative state to fix this problem
it's a political problem you have to
understand that china hates us they're
trying to destroy us we are their
enemies and so you start
changing that relationship so for
instance you take your damn economy out
of china
do you do you think trump could have
stopped china i think he tried with his
his trade deal i mean he basically said
look you guys start buying more of our
stuff because you're stealing our stuff
right so that's the thing that right now
people are forgetting
biden is actually thinking about getting
rid of the tariffs but trump actually
said look no the tariffs ultimately are
about saying to the chinese you still
steal billions of dollars of our economy
our intellectual property every [ __ ]
year so you're going to start paying
more through these tariffs or it's a
penalty right so now biden's going to
get rid of them well then what lesson
have the chinese
learn
they can keep stealing ourselves so so
my question i suppose was
if trump was working towards ending
this expanding dominance of the chinese
economy and taking of our infrastructure
our manufacturing things like that i
should say our economic infrastructure
and the spies weren't able to stop it
but they were able to stop trump they've
effectively propped up china they've
they've secured our doom on the global
stage
yeah i will point out it's uh not china
though it is the ccp the occupying force
of that land well amen the actual
government of china is a republic of
china located in taiwan and they are in
very good terms with what's right now
what would your deep state say if you
are right thank you sir what would the
deep state say if china unleashed this
like let's just call it a virus
and like it went worldwide would there
be penalties
fcc obviously the chinese people are men
they're they're stuck under that
totalitarian they are occupying forces
for real right now and mao like seize
control but removing the economy from
china we saw during covid how
90 95 of our pharmaceutical is is based
in china
nothing has been done to change that now
we look at similar geopolitics we look
at ukraine and we say boy this was
really bad that we import 60 percent of
our fertilizer from from russia nothing
will change about that we used to
produce our own pharmaceuticals we used
to produce our own fertilizer the whole
gulf coast was where we got them
why did we ever move these industries
overseas and show me one person in the
senate and there are lots of pro-america
i hate china i hate russia senators and
they're all on the right show me one of
them who is making a concerted effort to
say i don't care what the global market
says astrazeneca pfizer merck uh you
know fertilizer all of you have to come
back to america because there is a there
is a geopolitical and national security
risk to having these critical you want
to get your olive oil from italy that's
great get your cheese from france
totally cool but your fertilizer can't
be made by your enemy nor can your
aspirin but there is not one serious
piece of legislation to bring or
movement to bring all these things back
to america none whatsoever well just
watch china do it again and say wow that
was really bad but you know thanks for
my iphone so this is
maybe i'm just uh to be honest a circle
surface level dude i'm sitting here
reading the internet thinking i know so
much about you know geopolitics and
international conflict and i assume
there's probably some cia or fbi guy
sitting in his in his in his office with
all this classhead information just
laughing being like oh if only you
really knew maybe that's the case i hope
but but i i do i do because i want to be
right exactly i want to believe they're
sitting there saying like here's why we
had to do what we did because we are
concerned about china taking over we are
concerned about these these uyghur camps
we're concerned about the belt and road
initiative we're concerned about oil
exploration in south america but really
what it feels like is trump derangement
syndrome went viral
within these these agencies
trump actually was doing things that
were good on foreign policy
and they stopped him
they stopped him and that's the problem
of the deep state the administrative
state you know what the media tries to
do they try to make you think the deep
state is a cabal of people who meet
below dc with robeson and have like a
pentagram on the ceiling no it's just
that people who get jobs hollywood
that's right that's hollywood what it
actually is that's why that's why ian
brought up administrative stakes
it's people who don't get fired
they're they're working there for 20
years between a bunch of different
presidents and you know obama gets
elected he sits down and they say here's
what's happening and here's our plan and
the president goes okay i guess dude and
so they just do whatever they want as
long as they want j edgar hoover was the
head of the fbi for 48 years 47 some
years like he ran the country he was
running the country 47 years he headed
the it was ahead of the fbi i mean i've
never been in the fbi but i mean what's
the power i would imagine that power
level is immense
amen so particularly without going into
the history of the fbi he absolutely
decided the political winners and losers
of this country and that's really what
happened during the 2020 and 2016
election particularly 2016 with hillary
clinton and trump right so
after trump was elected you had a bunch
of former cia and fbi officials james
comey leaking classified information to
force the appointment of a special
counsel holy crap yeah i mean this is
one man an fbi director who decided that
trump should not be in power
not because there was actual data or
information that said we had a problem
but he just didn't like the guy so he
goes to the new york times leaks it in
order to get bob mueller that is j edgar
hoover level stuff and we haven't seen
that in a long long time i foolishly
believed that we it those dark days were
over but that showed me that not it
ain't gone there were still absolutely
people in positions without authority
and power who still do this jagger
hoover's the suspect trial stuff is
crazy yeah we had cash baton the other
day
and uh
it's just shocking the fbi knew it was
bunk almost immediately you had
apparently one guy testified that
hillary clinton knew and signed off on
on the russia gate narrative fabrication
wow
the the the the agents as assessment
himself who who lied on the fisa warrant
to get these um um
against paige to get the fisa yeah so
that that's the same guy it is the same
level of of corruption and negligence
and evil and dereliction of duty
on a different level but it's the same
idea as the 19 guys in texas who stood
in the hallway and listened to the
gunshots this is exactly what your
mission is and you're like yeah but i'm
not gonna do it like you know this is a
lie yeah but i'm not gonna do it like
you know what your job is right now and
the oath you have taken
yeah i'm gonna do the opposite
you know i'll tell you on
one piece that the last couple weeks i
did on my podcast and talked a lot about
that that doesn't i think get enough
attention 107 000 people last year died
because of fentanyl or drug overdoses
most of them of the hundred seven
thousand were fentanyl the point is most
of that comes from china those are
precursor chemicals that come from china
china knows
these companies that are producing it
they know that they in turn are dealing
with mexican cartel members
and it's then all feeding into this
country china is killing 100 plus
thousand of our people
why are we not all like outraged that
that the the communist government in
beijing is doing this in concert in
collaboration with mexican cartels it is
just it should be getting far more
attention certainly than even ukraine i
mean as much as that that
absolutely runs the risk of world war
three and i think we can talk about that
as well because i think we're getting
there
that issue of dead americans in this
country especially in rural america is
so real and so painful for me personally
but for so many others it's it deserves
more of our attention and that's why
because it's rural america and we were
saying to this before the show started
if the overdoses of from fentanyl and
chinese opioids
uh were upper east side uh uh
collegiates
this would have been stopped by now but
it's mostly rural mostly poor mostly
hillbilly whites and we don't really
care they targeted the farmers it's just
exactly it is not a population the
american government care about because
they don't like them even their own
their representatives don't like them
look for any liberal who represents a
rural state who's running for office
even they are ashamed of their
constituency they don't care but i'm
gonna tell you right now in pima county
arizona where i am from
if you're a kid the the thing that's
going to get you in terms of the thing
that's going to kill you is fentanyl
right now it's not car accidents it's
not there it is fentanyl and pima county
is not a rural you know white hillbilly
area it's you are right the
preponderance is absolutely that is true
but it's hitting communities in lots of
parts of this country black brown it
doesn't matter it is hitting our young
people most especially because that [ __ ]
part of my language is mixed up with
weed or with other stuff and they're
like hey let's experiment let's try and
have a good time and then they end up
dead because there's just such tiny
amounts of that that they end up killing
you i find it to be an extension of the
opium wars apparently this is when the
british and other europeans were
shuffling opium into china they were
basically colonizing china in the
mid-1800s and they're like we're going
to wreck their population make them
incapable of fighting and then we're
going to conquer it and take it as
another colony like what they did with
india but the chinese eventually fought
back and pushed them back to the coast
and off and into taiwan or hong kong or
these these islands
um but it never ended for them they play
the long game any any wise
regime thinks hundreds of years in the
future and will never never forget
what's what people are capable of and
that's what they're doing they're
sending into mexico like you said with
the cartels using them to run it up into
the country they're destabilizing our
youth you see it in the
you know dysphoria movement um you see
in the shootings
and the the pharmaceutical companies
seem to be capitalizing on it they've
actually created medical fentanyl you
can i mean i don't know who's in charge
is it astrazeneca who who actually
prints this stuff this this stuff
they're working colluding with the ccp
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there